Hello, and welcome to Al Dente Creepypasta.
Horror stories cooked to perfection with a
splash of red sauce.
My name is CZ and I will be your server this
episode.
Today’s portion was written to take the
holly and jolly out of the holidays, and replace
them with hate and misery.
This shocking ending will leave you devastated.
Let’s dig right in.
For the last couple of years, my wife and
I have hosted a Secret Santa gift exchange
during the holidays.
It’s a fairly new tradition, but we thought
it was nice to put together since us and a
lot of our friends can’t really afford to
buy gifts for everyone.
We do it a little bit differently than some
people might be accustomed to.
Everyone randomly gets a name and has to buy
that person a gift around $50.
We have one get together where everyone opens
their gifts, but even after the swap, you
never find out who gave you the gift.
My wife and I agreed that part is important.
She says that what makes the holiday special
is having good faith in all our friends to
get the person something good.
In other words, if you’re only buying a
gift in order to get recognition for it, than
the whole idea is kind of cheapened.
Besides.
These are our friends.
If you can’t trust them, then who can you
trust?
Sure, there are exceptions where it’s obvious
who gave the gift; like last year when our
friends Emily and Alaina, who are married,
ended up getting each other.
Or… also last year; when Cynthia received
a cheap ice tray as her gift from her recently
ex-boyfriend, Marc.
We were optimistic that this year would be
filled with positivity… which it was…
to a point anyway.
We have a secret santa app that automatically
emails everyone involved and tells them who
they got.
It’s great, because it allows us as the
organizers to not get our Secret Santas spoiled.
I got Troy, the newest addition to our party
this year.
I think I got the perfect gift for him too.
Every time I go over to his apartment, there’s
stuff everywhere.
Plates, silverware, Blu-Rays…
It’s not like he’s just too lazy to clean
up after himself, it just seems like he doesn’t
have anywhere to put it all.
So I got him one of those knife blocks, a
dishrack and a silverware organizer.
That will just cover the kitchen, but it’s
a start.
I had a feeling Troy was going to appreciate
it.
The day of the gift exchange arrived.
We had people drop off gifts in a pile as
they came in.
We all enjoyed some drinks and snacks as we
caught up with each other for a couple hours
before getting to down to it.
By the time we started to open the gifts,
everyone was getting a bit…
giggly.
My wife pointed out that Troy seemed to have
taken an interest in her friend Cynthia, which
we could both get behind since they were the
only two there who were still single.
It seemed like the party was alive and well.
Most of the gifts were really good too, and
people kept up their poker faces as far as
I could tell when the present they brought
was being opened.
Of course, there were a couple obvious ones,
like our friend James who most likely got
his own wife, seeing as how she didn’t know
how anyone else would have known what she
wanted this year.
Marco actually ended up getting two presents
somehow.
I couldn’t figure out why.
I was worried that the app had messed up and
someone was going to end up with no presents,
but I did a quick count and realized there
were 11 total presents for the 10 of us.
I guess someone just wanted to make Marco’s
day and get him something in addition to buying
something for their person.
He ended up loving both presents, so it seemed
like no harm done for the most part, though
I just worried it was a bit unfair to everyone
else.
The final present remaining came down to my
wife.
It was a little black box wrapped in… what
looked to be just a plastic trash bag and
tied up in actual rope.
It was…
I’m not going to lie, a really ugly exterior,
and she had a lot of trouble opening it by
herself.
In fact, nobody could seem to pry the knot
off of it, granted we were all kind of drunk
at that point, so we ended up having to cut
the thing open.
She opened the box… and pulled out a small
piece of paper.
She looked upset as she read it.
Then her hands started to shake and her eyes
glazed over.
“What is it?”
She showed me the slip of paper.
There were just a couple of words on it.
“Santa says… you all die.”
I quickly looked inside the box, only to find,
there was nothing else inside.
I can get kind of defensive at times and I
got pretty upset and took it out on everyone.
Within a couple minutes the party was over
and everyone was out in the cold.
I wanted to get to the bottom of who the hell
thought this would be funny by asking everyone
who who their secret santa was and doing a
little research of my own to find out who
was lying, but she insisted that it wasn’t
that big of a deal and she’d rather not
ruin it for everyone.
Still, I felt really betrayed.
These were supposed to be our friends, and
I couldn’t understand who would want to
hurt her like that.
But we were tired and just decided to retire
to bed for the evening.
I told myself I would get her something great
to make up for it and started brainstorming
some gift ideas.
But all I could think about was… who would
do this?
I stayed awake for a while longer trying to
think of any reason that someone would have
to try to spook us.
That’s when I heard…
someone rummaging around the house.
A chill went up my spine and after being frozen
in fear for a few moments, I sat up and began
to formulate a plan.
My wife woke up and asked me what I was doing.
“There’s someone in the house.
Stay here keep the door locked until I give
you the OK.”
With that, I slipped out and locked the door
behind me.
My blood was boiling at this point.
I didn’t know if this had anything to do
with the present from earlier but all I wanted
to do was find who was behind this and bash
his head in.
The only issue was…
I couldn’t hear anyone moving around anymore…
It seemed that the house was quiet.
I methodically checked the entire upstairs.
It was empty.
As I was checking the last closet, I heard
a huge crash from downstairs.
I sprinted down, fists blazing, but the scene
I found in the living room was far more horrifying
than I could have imagined.
The tree had been knocked over into the fireplace
which was now on and it had begun to burn.
I heard footsteps running to the door, but
I knew I couldn’t go after him now.
In a panic, I turned off the gas fireplace
and ran to the kitchen to grab a jug of water.
I poured it over the tree which was beginning
to burn even more, but all I could manage
to do was slow down the rapidly spreading
fire.
Luckily my wife had already called 9-1-1 and
the fire department showed up before long.
I was able to slow down the fire enough until
they arrived.
I wish I could say that was the end of it.
But it gets worse from there.
The police showed up and questioned us about
what had gone down that evening.
We told the entire story, and they were particularly
interested in the app we had used to sort
the names for the secret santa.
The chief told us that an undercover police
officer would be on our block for the time
being, and to call 9-1-1 if we had any other
disturbances.
He also gave me a card, a point of contact
for if we had any other information.
It was nearly 4AM at that point, and we were
ready to put this nightmarish evening behind
us when I got a call from Terry, James’s
wife.
They were both at the secret Santa that night
and I noticed a couple of missed calls from
from her as well.
Desperate for more information, I picked up,
but before I could explain the mess that we
had been in, she explained that she was calling
from the hospital.
Apparently they had been driving home from
our house when some maniac ran them off the
road!
She was fine, but went on to explain that
James had been injured pretty badly, though
he was expected to make a recovery.
I decided that enough was enough.
It was time to do a little investigation of
my own.
The next morning I headed out to the spot
of the crash, as Terry had described to me.
If I was going to get to the bottom of this,
I had to be thorough.
Afterall, as far as I knew Terry was trying
to cover up her or James’s guilt with that
phone call.
I found tire tracks going off the road, but
that really only clears one of them.
I made a call on over to the hospital.
I knew they wouldn’t share any information,
since that’s someone’s private medical
info, but I acted like a concerned family
member and asked if they’d been found.
I was able to find out they both got admitted
at the same time, so they were both in the
clear.
My next step was finding out who they got
gifts for in the secret santa, which involved
me showing up and asking to see the email.
I had to catch them by surprise to make sure
they didn’t try to doctor anything.
So I knew I had Troy and my wife had Emily.
It was already fairly obvious that James had
his wife Terry, but I did find out that Terry
had Alaina.
Don’t worry about keeping track of all the
names, just know that my list of suspects
was narrowing.
I also discovered that the person who went
after them was in a white van with black tape
over the license plate.
Next on my list were Emily and Alaina.
It took me a while to come up with an idea
about how I might prove their whereabouts,
but I ended up finding a way to check on them
without either of them knowing.
See, every year there’s this big Christmas
tree in town square.
Everyone in the town is encouraged to put
up an ornament of their own, and the whole
thing is livestreamed for the entire month
of December.
They would most certainly go past it on their
way home.
All I had to do was go back to last night
around the time they should have been driving
home.
Luckily enough, I was able to spot their car
on the stream.
While that didn't necessarily clear both of
them from what happened at our house, it did
make them innocent of running James and Terry
off the road.
Unless they had just gotten a second car that
I don't know about, but I figured I could
reevaluate them if that came to be the case.
I also had to make the assumption that the
intruder at our house and the crazy driver
that went after our friends were related incidents,
and the time frame of the events seemed to
line up with that theory.
Of course, the nasty present my wife received
only backed this idea up further.
I tried getting ahold of Emily and Alaina
to see who they got gifts for, but neither
one could be reached.
The next and final couple was Marco and Gina.
They’d taken an Uber home from the party,
so all I had to do was show up and ask to
see their ride history.
When I arrived Marco was actually kind of
upset that I was accusing them.
I thought to myself, this was it.
It must be one of them.
But I hadn’t really planned for what I would
do if I’d gotten this far.
I didn’t bring anything to defend myself
with.
Not only was Macro a big guy, but it was 2
against one.
I clenched my fists behind my back and slowly
stepped away as Marco yelled at me, going
on about how he was appalled that I didn’t
trust him after everything we’d been through.
I figured that my best bet was to turn and
run for my car.
Then I could hopefully make a getaway and
alert the police.
Tension within me built as I waited for him
to make a move.
Just when I was ready to turn and run, Gina
came up with the phone to her ear and said
that Terry was on the line, and she had just
found out about the car crash.
She invited me in to show me the evidence
I was looking for, and stupidly, I accepted.
For all I knew, this could have been an act
to lure me in and make me more vulnerable.
Still, when Gina delivered the news, I thought
I saw something change in Marco’s expression.
Like an understanding had come over him.
Like he realized now why I had to see their
whereabouts last night.
Still I was jumpy inside of their house and
in my mind I was keeping track of where they
both were at all times for my own safety,
though I tried not to show it.
Marco brought up their trip history on Uber
and… to my surprise, they had gone home
after the party, no doubt about it.
They also showed me who their secret santa
recipients were: Marco’s was Cynthia and
Gina’s was James.
I told them I had to be on my way and headed
out, where a van was pulling up to the curb
by their house.
As soon as I looked up at it, it haphazardly
sped away down the street.
I ran after it and found that the license
plate was covered with black tape, it was
just like what Terry had described to me.
I dialed 9-1-1 and let them know what had
just happened.
He was still going after people, so I knew
I was racing the clock here.
There were only two suspects left: Troy and
Cynthia, the two singles who had been flirting
at the party.
I hoped to God it wasn’t Troy after I had
put so much into my gift for him, but deep
down I knew it was.
The nature of the crime at my house pointed
to it being a male.
Still, I touched base with my wife and told
her to look into Cynthia while I confronted
him.
Everything was boiling down to this.
Troy lived alone so I wouldn’t be able to
get any info from anyone else.
He did live in an apartment complex however,
so there had to be a camera somewhere that
would prove he was out several hours later
after the party ended.
I gave the police chief a call and he agreed
to send someone to meet me at Troy’s apartment
complex with a warrant.
I waited out by the office.
This was our chance to nail him.
What was it taking them so long?
As I waited around…
I heard a familiar voice.
It was Troy.
I was so stupid.
Of course he'd come back here after nearly
getting caught back at Marco’s.
This was not good.
He knew I knew.
But he didn't let onto it right away.
Well, two can play at that game.
My only choice was to play dumb.
He pretended to be surprised to see me.
He always did have a good poker face.
I told him that I had come to check on him
when I heard about James and Terry.
He told me he had just heard this morning
and went over to the hospital to visit James.
He was finally telling me something I could
believe.
A good move on his part.
It would definitely make them less suspicious
of him.
But that wouldn't work on me.
I'd caught him red handed.
But he knew I knew too much.
What was his plan?
How long was he going to play dumb?
All I had to do was stall a little bit longer.
I decided to press him on it.
I asked if anything weird had happened after
he had left the night before.
I was hoping to trip him up with an inconsistency
in his story.
Something that didn't line up with the actual
timeline of events.
All I got out of him though, was that he had
gone straight home.
He asked what I had done after everyone had
left.
And it was at that moment that something clicked
in my head.
He was going to try paint me as the villain.
He knew we would be home and asleep after
the party, so we would have no alibi to prove
that we hadn't gone and run down James’s
car before coming back to set our own Christmas
tree ablaze in an attempt to make ourselves
look like victims.
After all, we'd setup the party.
We could have structured it so that my wife
would receive the creepy note… from me.
He was going to try to pin it all on me.
But I was one step ahead of him.
The detective arrived.
I told Troy he was busted, but I knew it would
be a battle to prove my own innocence as well.
He continued to play dumb.
The detective provided the apartment complex
with a warrant and we all sat down to watch
the footage.
This next part, I deeply regret.
I'll never be able to erase that look of betrayal
out of my mind.
Because the footage proved that Troy was innocent.
I wish I had more time to apologise for accusing
him, but I had to go check on my wife.
All signs now pointed to Cynthia being the
culprit.
I rushed home where my wife informed me she
had just gotten off the phone with Cynthia’s
roommate.
Cynthia was also innocent.
This didn't make any sense.
We'd cleared everyone who was at the party.
Had we overlooked someone?
Was it somebody else?
Outside of the group?
We soon got our answer.
If you're easily disturbed, I suggest you
don't continue.
We got another call from the police chief.
Emily and Alaina were dead.
Somebody had broken down their door and slit
both of their throats, leaving them to bleed
out under the Christmas tree.
The killer had also slathered a message on
the carpet in blood.
It read, “lesbo freaks” with arrows pointed
up at them.
I was sickened just by hearing about this.
But the police had a strong lead on who the
killer might be.
Marc Berklee.
Cynthia’s ex from last year's secret santa.
The a-hole who got her an ice tray for a gift.
Apparently, one of the first things the detective
on our case did was contact the developer
of the secret santa app.
He was given a master list of everyone involved.
I guess we never removed Marc from the list
when we added Troy this year and the app told
Troy to get a present for Marc.
Troy must have thought it supposed to be Marco,
seeing as how he would have no idea who Marc
even is.
That would also explain why Marco ended up
with two gifts.
Then Marc must have snuck in at some point
and dropped my wife’s gift into the pile.
It was all starting to come together.
We also found out that Marc completely lost
his mind when Cynthia had broken up with him
a little over a year ago.
There were multiple police reports of him
threatening her, stalking her and loitering
outside of her apartment.
Maybe when Marc accidentally got the email
about our secret santa that somehow set him
off again and he decided to terrorize all
of us.
Everyone still in her life.
Everyone who is as close to her as he wishes
he could be.
The chief told me he had already sent his
squad over to Cynthia’s, as Marc would likely
be heading there next after having hit every
other couple at the party.
But I knew that wouldn't be the case.
If Marc really had snuck into my party to
deliver the fake gift, he'd have seen what
went on between Cynthia and Troy and he'd
be in a furious rage.
He was saving his best, most brutal and cold-blooded
strike for last and Cynthia was never on his
hit list.
I raced over to Troy’s as quickly as I could,
but feared I may be too late when I arrived
to find his front door had been left wide
open.
I walked inside.
It seemed…
strangely empty.
My heart sank.
Was I too late?
Or was Troy even home when Marc had arrived?
I called out.
“Troy?”
No response.
“Marc?”
I headed into the kitchen where I saw that
the dish rack and silverware organizer I'd
gotten him had been put to good use.
He'd finally tidied his crazy mess of stuff.
For that little moment I was glad I was able
to get him something worthwhile.
But then it happened.
I never heard it coming.
But I did see a shadow come over me as I noticed
the other gift I had gotten Troy.
The knife block.
But… one of knives was missing.
---
Thanks for listening to Al Dente Creepypasta.
Your total comes out to $50, but if you like
this video right now you'll get everything
you just listened to, absolutely free.
This episode has been brought to you by the
CZsWorld Merch Store.
Check the link in the description to get get
these cool designs such as CZsWorld and Kill,
CZsWorld Cafe and more.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I'll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.